abone ol
çok
selamlar gördüğünüz gibi oldukça iddialı
bir başlık üstünden ilerleyeceğim
bugünkü konuşmamı
Buraya geçmemeliydim nasıl oldu
bilmiyorum Peki Dursun
Nereden geldiniz neden geldiniz Nereye
gideceksiniz konu bu çok şükür süper bir
başlık gibi gelebilir size ve fakat biz
biliyoruz ki görünen
görünmeyenden kaynak alır bütün
felsefenin ve sonrasında Onun içinden
gelişmiş olan psikoloji biliminin
dayandığı yer budur Esasen bilimsel
araştırma dediğimiz olgu
dataların elde ettiğimiz dataların
yorumlanmasında ibarettir ve araştırmacı
Evet Ee bu yorum yaparken
mutlaka kendinden bir şeyler Katar dosya
bilimsel araştırmanın sonuçları da yiyor
dolanırken yorumlanırken
bir bilinmezin içinde durduğumuzu Biz
her zaman biliriz yani her şeyi
bildiğimizi asla düşünmeyiz bu büyük bir
yanılsama olur şimdi başlık Çok iddialı
ve Acaba bunu herkes sormalı mı diye
düşündüğümüz zaman benim kendi verdiğim
cevap Evet sormalı bu çok önemli
sosyal medyada
dolaşan minik bir
paylaşımı şiiri okuyarak başlayalım 27
yaşındaki bir çocuğun yazdığı şiir
annesine götüreyim öde şaşkınlıkla
karşılıyor sonra Twitter'da
bayağı etkilendiği insanlar oldukça
dikkat çekti şöyle diyor Ben neyim Ben
bir kara delik miyim ben bir kek miyim
acaba burada bildiğimiz kekimi
kastediyor Yoksa sen çekin tekisin Hadi
bizik eklemeyin falan o argo konuşma dan
çıkan bir şey mi bilmiyorum Ben 12 miyim
Çok derin bir cümle bunun üstüne bir
ayrı bir tez konuşması yapabilirim Ben
bir İsmail miyim ben bir hiç miyim Ya
ben bir hiçliğin ortasında yüzen bir
adam mıyım ben hiçbir şey miyim Yoksa
bunlar bir yalan mı
ya belki bir şey olabilirim
34 Mayıs 2022 herhalde Ayvalık'ta
yazmışım şimdi
çocuklar çok spontan varlıklar ve bugün
size
psikodrama grup psikoterapisi ve
sosyometri sistemi içindeki Eee önemli
kavramlardan bahsederek
görünene bakıp oradan görünmeyene dair
bir kestirim yapmayı hedefliyoruz
ve bu kestirme yaptığımız zaman benimle
hemfikir olmayabilirsiniz ama en azından
sizin de bir yorumunuz olacaktır
görüneni gördükten sonra
bu peki bunu değiştiremiyor
LOL Bebek spontan Doğuyor
var yani anne ile bebeğin ilk
etkileşimleri en güçlü etkileşimleri
doğum anında gerçekleşir ve orda spawn
tam bir eylem gerçekleşiyor hepimiz
spontan varlıklarız bu kavramın içini
1-2 dakika açmak istiyorum sponte
kelimesinden geliyor spontan it it
Latince'de özgür irade demek
Sen neyi nasıl yapmak istiyorsak onu
yapma iradesi
kelimenin kökeninin dolması çok anlamlı
Çünkü
yaşamdaki amaçlarımızdan bir tanesi
spontan olmak
bu aynı zamanda otantik de olmak
bizim buradaki varlığımız kendi spontan
ünitemizi deneyimlemek
bu birinci altını çizmek istediğim
gerçeklik bu görüneni konuşuyoruz şimdi
ki bu bile çok Çıplak gözle görünmüyor
olabilir Herkese aynı fikirde
olmayabilir
LOL bebek yine doğduğunda Her birimiz
bir eylem açlığı ile doğuyoruz ve bu
bizim
bu hayatımız boyunca
merakımızı öğrenmemizi kişisel
gelişimimizi etkileyen en önemli faktör
oluyor Eylem açlığı son derece önemli
bir meseledir bir problem değildir bir
hazinedir bizim için demek ki Eylem
açlığını gidermek için de buradayız
ettiği ki spontan olmak için buradayız
Eylem açlığını gidermek için buradayız
bu organik plazenta dan annesinin
karnında mutlu bir yaşantı da sosyal bir
Plaza Antalya doğuyor
ilk ilişkisi anne ve doktor daha sonra
akrabalar Baba vesaire giriyor
hayatımıza ve Geniş çevre
Şimdi biz buna sosyometri bilimin ışığı
altında bakıyoruz Şimdi üçüncü
gerçekliğe geliyorum
da
başkalarının olmadığı bir hayat Hayal
edemeyiz Moreno yani psikodramanın
kurucusu diyor ki
yalnız insan ilişkileri olmayan insan
bir kurgudan ibarettir öyle bir şey
olamaz diyor İyi o zaman bir gerçekliğe
daha geliyoruz bu dünyada başkaları için
varız başkaları yoksa bizde yokuz etti
33 devam edelim
LOL Bebek doğduğu andan itibaren
seçimler yapmaya başlıyor bir süre sonra
bu seçimler üç türlü oluyor istiyoruz
çekiyoruz ya da ilgisiz kalıyoruz ne
Türk alıyoruz yaptığımız bütün seçimleri
bilebilseydim sizin falcı ihtiyacınız
kalmayacaktı geleceğinizi size
söyleyebilirim bugün yaptığımız bütün
seçimler bizi geleceğe taşıyor Board
dolayısıyla bir diğer önemli noktanın
Altını çiziyorum niye buradayız seçim
yapmak için
bu seçimler bize bizi gösteriyor
seçimlerimizi spontan yapıyoruz ve bütün
bunları bir başka konuya geçiyorum bir
rolün içinde yapıyoruz
akademisyen önünde başka seçimler
yapıyorsunuz sevgili rolünde başka
seçimler yapıyorsunuz anneyken başka
seçimler yapıyorsunuz
duygusal bir ölünün içinde Örneğin
kızgınız kızan rolünü aldınız seçimler
yapıyorsunuz değil mi yapıp karşıdakinin
kafasını kırıyorsunuz ya da öyle
yaratıcı bir cümle söylüyorsunuz ki o
size diyor ki dövsen daha iyiydi
şimdi
rollerin içindeki seçimler ve var
Ancak ve ancak rolü alırsanız mümkün
Bu bir diğer elim bir konuya daha
geçiyorum rol almak rol oynamak ve rol
yaratmak
rolü alırsanız
He he çok da diye ama çok tavsiye
etmiyoruz Onu oynamak lazım
oynarsanız kültürel konserveleri içinde
kalıyorsun ya seviyorlar iyi bir baba
böyle olur iyi bir hoca şöyle olur iyi
sevgili budur en iyi cinsel Partner
söyle olur Bunu oynuyorsanız biz
kültürel kalıpların içinde durursunuz
Ama son aşamaya sıçrarsa kız becerirsin
iz Bunu o rol yaratmadır rolü
yaratırsınız size Özge olur İşte o an
spontan olursunuz otantik olursunuz Ve o
an kendinizi keşfetmeye başlarsınız yani
yaşam yolculuğunda kendimizi keşfetmek
en önemli amaçlarımızdan bir tanesi dir
Ama bu su götürmez gerçekleri arka
arkaya sıraladığımız zaman
önemli bir tablo çıkıyor bir çerçeve ve
neden buradayız
bu konuşmamın başında başlık nasıldı
Nereden geldik Neden Geldik nereye
gideceğiz benim konuşmam
Evet şu anda yaptıklarımızla Emine'den
geldiğimizde ilgili Bununla ilgili
benimle hemfikir olabilirsiniz peki Eğer
rolleri almak spontan olmak ve yaratıcı
olabilmek ve bütün bunları bir eylem
içinde yapabilmek bu kadar önemliyken
seçimler yapmak bu kadar önemliyken ve
bu dünyadaki varlık varlığımız bu
şekilde ilerlerken cesareti ihtiyacımız
olduğu su götürmez bir Gerçek cesur
sanız ileriye gideceksiniz
keşfedeceksiniz Eylem içinde olacaksınız
rolünüzü geliştireceksiniz o Sero
repertuar gelişmiş insanlar farklı
rolleri alabilir insanlar ve onu
kendisine göre oynayan otantik bir
varoluşu şimdi onu yaşayan insanlar
gelişmeye başlıyor Belki o zaman şuraya
yavaş yavaş gelebiliriz şu konuyu ya
nereden gelmiş olabiliriz
o Herkes bu sorunun cevabını arıyorsun
değil mi Ben nereye gideceğiz yani ölür
Ödeyeceğiz ve ne olacak ve doğduk
nereden doğduk bu birinci bir varsayımı
bütün bu bilgilere bakarak çok basit pek
de itiraz edilemez gibi duruyor Eğer
Burası Eylem içinde seçim yaparak
spontane temizle bilmediğimiz Bir
geleceğin içinde yolculuk yapmak
öğrenmek gelişmek ve keşfetmek ise bu
bir müfredat programıdır
ne demek ki Geldiğimiz Yer müfredat
programının yapıldığı
bu burası ise bu programın aktive
edildiği yer olmalı
ve eğer bunu da buraya benzer bir yerden
geldiyse buraya gelmeye gerek yok yani
bir çiftliğiniz varsa etini sütünüzü
yoğurdumuzu ve meyve nizi sebzesi
kendiniz üretiyorsunuz markete
gitmezsiniz Biz Eğer Burası Market sebze
Demek ki çiftliğimiz yok Türkçesi
Bu eylemsiz bir yerden geliyor olmalıyız
keşifle ilgili olmayan bir yerden
geliyor olmalıyız
yaratıcılığa ihtiyaç olmayan bir yerden
geliyor olmalıyız hayat
Ama siz belli bir yolda giderken
karşınıza çıkanlar diye tanımlanabilir
Bu neden böyle söyledim çünkü Eğer
yoldan saparsa nıza planları bep
planları devreye giriyor c planları
devreye giriyor nedir Onlar kazalar
krizler çeşitli olaylar Tabii ki onları
Siz hazırlıyorsunuz
seçimlerinizle
nereye gideceğiz Bu da diğer soru
bu Eğer böyle bir müfredat programının
içindeysek ve bu spontan yaşam içinde
kendinizi keşfediyor Sak küçük bir ek
yaparı yaparak bunu netleştirebilirim
xbiz bir müfredat programınızı olsa bile
bunu değiştirebiliyoruz öyle gözüküyor
ve yaratıcılık bunu gerekli kılıyor yani
burada Özgür iradesi
zp Çünkü gerçeklik bu izin veriyor
diyorsunuz yani Biz buradayız bu dünya
dayız dedik konuşması yapıyoruz Ben
hazırlanıyorum Uzmanlar hazırlanıyor çok
önemli bilgiler paylaşıyoruz
çok yakınımızda bir yerde bir terör
eylemi gerçekleştiriyor bir yerde bir
hırsızlık oluyor olmadı Eziyetler
işkence var bu dünyada diyorsunuz
kendimi hepimiz aynı yalnız nasıl
olabilir yani ilahi bir adalet yok mu
Yok
neden yok çünkü izin var Özgür ya de
spontaneity aykırı olurdu Her şeyi izin
var burası bir deneyim alanı Peki her
şeyin varsa kötü yaşayan da iyi yaşayan
ve Felsefe böyle tanımlayabilir iyi kötü
diye bir şey yok diyoruz biz ama da
tanımlanabilir
en büyük bir deneyim sahibi olarak ölümü
takacaklar
ve buradan anlıyoruz ki biz Gideceğimiz
yer
bu Geldiğimiz yere benzer ve fakat bir
farklılığı içeriye olmalı bir müfredat
programının değerlendirilmesi
yapılıyor olmalı
bu ne yaşadım ben neyi seçtim Neyi
seçmedim
de diyebilirsiniz ki bu çok şükür Güzel
bir yaklaşım gelebilir kulaklarınıza
böyle gelebilir Biz yıllardır Skoda ve
grup psikoterapisi içinde
biz bunları çalışıyoruz
danışanları hızla bisikletlerle
psikologlarla bir çocuk danışmanlarla
eğitim alanlarla ve ne kadar güçlü bir
öğrenmeye ihtiyaçları olduğunu orada
görüyoruz öğrenmeler tamamlanınca
seçimleri değişiyor Hayat Yolları
değişiyor planları değişiyor
ama bazen çevreleri için acı verici
oluyor bazen onları da değiştirmeye
başladı her zaman onları değiştirmeye
başlıyorlar ve buradan anlıyoruz ki
yaşamın değerlendirilmesi yaşamak kadar
kıymetli
Bu
değerlendirilmemiş bir yaşamın ya da
yaşanmamış bir
yaşamın değerlendirilmesi kıymetli değil
tersi de doğru kıymetli değil kıymetli
olması lazım orta yaşı geçen herkes ve
bu sürenin yani yaşam bilmemizin kısa
olduğunu düşünmeye başlamış olabilirler
çok kısa gerçekten öğrenecek çok şey yok
mu O zaman tek bir yaşam asılmış olamaz
bizim gelişmişliği miz mümkün değil
Şimdi diyebilirsin ki hocam
reenkarnasyonu mu savunuyorsunuz Ne
söylüyorsunuz Ben sadece görünenden
hareketle ne olabiliri tahmin etmiyordum
aya çalışıyorum gerçekten de mümkün
olabilir mi
bu 50-60 yıllık yetmiş yıllık bir yaşam
diliminde bu kadar şeyi öğrenebilir
misafir öğrenemeyiz kuşaklararası
aktarımı O yüzden çok önemli fakat
sanmayın ki kuşaklar arasında aktarım
bütün bilgilerimizi aktarılmasına olanak
sağlıyor Hayır öyle bir şey Mümkün getir
almaları alıyoruz kuşaklardan bazı
önemli kalıpları alıyoruz ama bütün
bilgileri alamayız bize ait bilgileri
alamayız koku uşaklar başka ona spontan
ikisi ayrı onlar başka insanlardı Biz
biri ciyiz Dolayısıyla ben kendim
öğreniyor olmalıyım her şeyi varsa
geldiğimde gittiğim yerlerdeki süreç
içinde yani bir yaşama sığdırılamayacak
kadar çok şeyi öğrenmek deneyin demek
zorundayız Ama şu anda bir yaşamı idrak
ediyoruz sadece
ve dolayısıyla bugünkü konuşmamda
sizlere nereden gelmiş olabileceğimiz
nereye gidecek olabileceğimiz konusunda
biraz bilgi vermek istedim varsayımlarda
bulunmak istedim yeni bir olarak
gideceğiz kaçınılmaz bir yere gidiyorsak
ve büyük bir deneyimle
çok farklı gideceğiz geldiniz yerden
ayrı olmayabilir ama yeni bir olarak
gideceğimiz kesin O yüzden
Benim danacizade tavsiyem Çünkü herkes
videosuz akıl vermeye çok sever şöyle
yapın böyle yapın ben o kadar sevmiyorum
olanı konuşmayı daha çok seviyorum Ama
küçük bir tavsiyede bulunabilirim bu
zaman dilimini nasıl geçirdiğinizi çok
dikkat edin büyük bir hazine ve çok
önemli değerlendirmeyi Muhtemelen Siz
yapacaksınız O yüzden Kendinizden
Saklayacak hiçbir şeyiniz olmayabilir
gittiğimiz zaman teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]